не встиг президент Путін анексувати
чотири області України як його війська
були змушені тікати з ключового міста в
одній з них А в інший українці прорвали
російську танкову оборону приниження
оборону російських командирів один з них
Рамзан Кадиров закликав Москву
застосувати тактичну ядерну зброю міг з
цього тижня з Києва Ігор Жовква
заступник керівника офісу президента
чи загнала Україна Путіна у кут звідки
він може застосувати свій ядерний
Арсенал Він можливо не має інших
інструментів на полі бою що протистояти
контрнаступу України Отже Україна
ставиться до цього серйозно і Міжнародне
співтовариство має до цього серйозно
поставитись
що сприяло успіхам збройних сил України
та чи зможуть вони зберегти набраний
темп як вони поводяться з українцями
яких підозрюють у колабораціонізмі і
чому двері для переговорів все ще міцно
зачинені
пане Ігорю раді вітати в програмі
конфліктом дякую за запрошення
у засубу вражаючий місяць вони звільнили
від російських військ понад 6 тисяч
квадратних кілометрів взяли один із
ключових вузлів постачання росіян на
Донеччині і здійснили прорив на
Херсонщині наскільки важливо ми для вас
є цю успіхи Як на полі бою так і
психологічно
дякую за це запитання справді успіхи на
полі бою є дуже важливими адже у перші
дні та місяці війни багато хто не вірив
що Україна взагалі зможе вистояти в цій
війні Не кажучи вже про те щоб досягти
великих успіхів але за ці сім з гаком
місяців війни ми довели передусім собі а
також світовій спільноті що можемо не
лише стримати російську агресію а й
зупинити її що можемо проводити
контрнаступи і Безперечно ми повернемо
всі наші території тому дуже важливо щоб
у нас були контрнаступи на багатьох
напрямах у нас великі успіхи у
Харківській області практично весь
регіон уже звільнено українськими
збройними силами короче результати
справді і в Донецькій області якщо ви
пам'ятаєте Росія хотіла захопити усю
Луганську та Донецьку області ще
спочатку цієї відкритої війни тому що
вони намагалися захопити їх з 2014 року
але жодних успіхів у них на Донецькому
та луганському напрямках не відбувається
і те саме на півдні навколо таксона там
наші збройні сили також просуваються
повільніше ніж у Харківській області Але
все ж таки це дуже важливо Це справді
має велике значення для ЗСУ це важливо
психологічно і для нашого народу для
кожного українського громадянина який
живе в Україні чи вимушено на час війни
покинув країну Але Усі ми і президент і
український народ і уряд по-своєму
допомагаємо наблизити цю перемогу а те
що роблять збройні сили України справді
викликає захоплення не лише в Україні а
думаю І у всьому світі
що призвело до такого приголомшливого
успіху на полі бою і Чи зможете ви
зберегти цю перевагу
по-перше Це звісно Сила та майстерність
українських збройних сил по-друге Це
пов'язано з технікою озброєнням та
боєприпасами які надходять усе більшій
кількості від наших західних партнерів
більшість країн до яких ми зверталися на
початку війни з проханням надати нам
додаткове важке озброєння додаткову
артилерію танки бронемашини реактивні
системи залпового вогню зараз нам
допомагають і це те що справді сприяє
нашому успіху Бо знаєте за допомогою
самих лише автоматів не повоюєш це
сучасна війна і Контрнаступ робить
можливим сучасний західне озброєння Так
у нас є певні запаси зброї що залишилися
у спадок від СРСР але зараз ми довели
собі та усьому світу що збройні сили
України можуть освоїти сучасне озброєння
НАТО і ми можемо ним воювати та
перемагати тому так я думаю ми зможемо
отримати ініціативу для нас було дуже
важливо розпочати цей Контрнаступ до
зими Тому що набагато легше проводити
Контрнаступ у ту пору року коли це
можливо взимку за набагато легше
змінювати позиції оборонятися тому наші
збройні сили зроблять усе можливе щоб
отримати взяти темп і просунутися вперед
як на вашу думку Кремль реагуватиме на
ваші успіхи я припускаю що ви не
очікуєте що Путін прийме поразку зниже
плечима і піде
Я думаю що поки він не має успіхів на
полі бою його збройні сили не є другою
за силою армією у світі яким він їх
зображав швидше за все він отримував
неправильні доповіді від генералів про
Силу російських збройних сил але як
реакцію на успіхи ЗСУ він ймовірно був
змушений використовувати кілька
інструментів одним із них були фіктивні
референдуми які він організував на
тимчасово окупованій українській
території він намагається здійснити
спробу чергової анексії яку 2014 році
тому зараз дуже важливо не повторити
помилок 2014 року коли світова спільнота
міжнародні партнери України Будьмо
відвертими розпали те що вчинив Путін
дійсно зараз дуже вдалий момент коли все
міжнародне співтовариство негативно
відреагувала на ці фіктивні референдуми
та спроби анексії озвучили свою позицію
в різних форматах та на різних рівнях і
тим самим допомогло Україні у боротьбі з
російським агресором
хіба небезпека не в тому що ви заганяєте
його в глухий кут і змушуєте реагувати
зрештою Він має системи озброєнь яких
немає у вас я говорю про ядерну зброю Як
ви оцінюєте ймовірність того що він
застосує як мінімум тактичну зброю
особливо якщо ви надалі здобуватимете
Перемоги
ну Дивіться це вже не вперше Під час
цієї війни коли Він шантажує усіх не
лише Україну а й увесь світ ядерною
хімічною чи біологічною зброєю тобто
Хіба ви не сприймаєте це всерйоз ми
ставимося до ядерних погроз серйозно
дивіться Він можливо немає інших
інструментів на полі бою що протистояти
контрнаступу України Отже Україна
ставиться до цього серйозно і Міжнародне
співтовариство має до цього серйозно
поставитись зрештою у світі є кілька
ядерних держав Вони мають відреагувати
вони повинні завадити йому це зробити
повинні сказати йому про жахливі
наслідки якщо він наважиться використати
ядерну зброю навіть частково на полі бою
або на якихось віддалених територіях Він
не повинен навіть думати про це Ось чому
Український президент говорив зі
світовими лідерами він нагадав їм
Україна не є ядерною державою у нас
немає ядерної зброї ви пам'ятаєте ми
добровільно віддали її
1994 року тому нам потрібно підтримка
інших я держав щоб захистити не лише
Україну не лише Європу а й увесь світ
від застосування ядерної зброї
за повідомленням деяких видань НАТО
попередила своїх членів про те що Росія
можливо збирається провести ядерні
Випробування або демонстрацію ядерної
зброї я попередження Україні та заходу
ви довіряєте цій інформації
ми довіряємо будь-який достовірні
інформації яку Нам надають партнери наші
західні партнери і безумовно
вони повідомили вам про це так напевно я
думаю що наші сили безпеки та розвід
служби мають бути в контакті зі своїми
партнерами у них має бути ця інформація
президент Зеленський пообіцяв що Україна
звільнить всі території захоплені Росією
Чи це стосується Криму і скажіть як ви
можете досягти цієї мети та водночас
мінімізувати ризики для цивільного
населення яка зараз живе в окупації
послухайте Крим - це Україна ви
пам'ятаєте формат який запропонував наш
президент сам із Кримської платформи
цього року він пройшов друге в онлайн
форматі звісно у ньому взяли участь 40
лідерів не лише Європи та
євроатлантичного простору А я
африканських азійських країн країн
Латинської Америки і кожен із них сказав
що Крим - це Україна і україна має усі
права на звільнення цієї території тому
відповідаючи на ваше запитання так
безумовно коли Мій президент говорить
про звільнення всіх територій України
він має на увазі усі території справді
всі території включаючи Кримський
півострів тобто кордони станом на 24
серпня
1991 року яким чином ми звільнимо Крим
про це дуже складно зараз говорити але
безперечно ця мета перебуває у нашому
полі зору
очевидно що російські війська є вашими
основними цілями чи вважаєте ви також
своєю законною мішенню цивільні
російські адміністрації тих кого
призначили керувати так званими
анексованими територіями
ми цивілізована країна ми не воюємо із
цивільним населенням це Росія воює коли
не зумівши перемогти українських
солдатів у день і вночі бомбардує
цивільні об’єкти цивільні цілі та
населення ми воюємо з ворогом а ворог -
це збройні сили Росії Якщо ви запитуєте
мене про тих все ще українців які
співпрацюють із окупаційними силами У
нас є інші інструменти перший інструмент
- Це санкції І до речі хочу подякувати
міжнародній спільноті яка вже готує
санкції для тих хто організовував
фіктивні референдуми другий інструмент
після того як ми переможемо кожен хто
співпрацював з окупаційною Владою хто
вбивав українських солдатів і мирних
жителів нести ми відповідальність саме
тому наш президент зараз допомагає за
створення міжнародного трибуналу для
росіян які відповідають за вбивство
українських солдатів та цивільних осіб
саме тому ми виносимо це питання на
розгляд Організації Об'єднаних Націй ми
звертаємось із цим питанням до наших
міжнародних партнерів Я думаю це буде
найкраще можливо спосіб покарати їх
важко довести чи не так пане Жовква як
відрізнити людей яких змушували під
дулом пістолета виконувати накази людей
яким погрожували фізичною розправою чи
родичам яких погрожували від людей які
хотіли допомогти росіянам це дуже
непрості випадки чи не так Це дуже
непрості випадки але я не думаю що ми
перші в історії хто має справу з
колабораціонізмом ми обов'язково
застосуємо історичний досвід Повірте всі
хто співпрацюють з власної волі будуть
покарані
пане жопа Минулого тижня крім погроз від
Путіна Ми почали прямий заклик до
України припинити військові дії та
почати говорити про мир ми готові до
цього сказав Путін Як ви розцінюєте таку
пропозицію
ви знаєте від початку цієї відкритої
війни ми чули багато звернень промов
доповідей Мій президент був готовий до
переговорів Мій президент навіть
сформував команду яка вела переговори з
російською делегацією ви пам'ятаєте було
кілька зустрічей і ми були готові до
плідних переговорів але не до перемовин
на російських умовах ви пам'ятаєте якось
росіяни навіть почали слухати українську
делегацію і навіть прийняли проєкт
пропозиції України а потім раптом Вони
повернулися до своєї колишньої позиції
можна вести переговори з Росією лише на
російських умовах можна вести переговори
лише враховуючи російські червоні лінії
можна вести переговори лише щодо
російських ультиматумів тепер ми чуємо
нарадив самого президента Путіна чи його
наближених що Росія готова якби Росія
була готова до переговорів не було б цих
фіктивних референдумів тому що ви
напевно пам'ятаєте слова мого президента
ще навесні він сказав Якщо Росія
наважиться провести псевдореферендуми
тоді з нею зокрема про що говорити тож
скажіть мені тепер про що говорити з
Росією якщо Росія незаконно намагається
анексувати ще чотири області України що
тоді є предметом переговорів
але хіба ваш президент не виклав власну
формулу Миру на яку росіяни ніколи не
погодяться Я маю на увазі викладені
Зеленським п'ять пунктів серед них
покарання Росією за агресію та
відновлення територіальної цілісності
України Я виключаю врегулювання сказав
він яке не ґрунтується на українській
формулі Миру або так або ніяк Хіба це не
ваша позиція
Це була формула Миру але Подивіться де
Зеленський заявив про неї вона була
озвучена з трибуни генеральної асамблеї
ООН справді це формула Миру президента
України але формула для всього світу ми
маємо свій досвід і Ми ділимося ним з
Міжнародним співтовариством погляньте що
коїться з Україною це більше не повинно
відбуватися в жодній країні агресор
відчуває що він не буде покараний тому
що немає жодного легального інструменту
тому що ООН не виконує свою функцію тому
що немає ніякого світового поліцейського
який може застосувати покарання щоб
такого більше не сталося президент
ділиться своєю формулою Миру Ви маєте
рацію будь-яка війна закінчується
переговорами тому рано чи пізно
переговори мають відбутися і ми будемо
готові домовлятися про умови Перемоги
України але такі переговори мають бути
результативними переговори мають можливо
поєднати наших партнерів з Україною і
саме тому Мій президент говорить про
гарантії безпеки після війни щоб ця
агресія більше не повторилася оскільки
Росія на жаль завжди буде агресивною
тому зараз Ми разом повинні подумати як
не тільки покласти край цієї агресії
покласти край війні але як зробити так
щоб ця агресія не повторилася в
майбутньому Або якщо вона станеться щоб
України були юридичні гарантії
забезпечення миру
нині двері для мирних переговорів міцно
зачинені чи не так нині переговори
вестимуться лише на полі бою
пане Жовква раді були бачити вас у нашій
програмі Дякуємо за те що приділили час
Дякую вам